تشهد ميشيغان الآن أكبر
عدد من حالات الاستشفاء المرغوبة
منذ بداية الوباء الذي
دفع ممرضة واحدة على الخطوط الأمامية
لتكشف بالتفصيل ما يشبه
علاج الاقتباس الكتابي غير الملقح ،
أساعدك على خلع معطفك والشعور
بالبرد  ما زلت متمسكًا بها ، يغرق قلبي
لأنني أعلم أن هذه ربما تكون
الليلة الأخيرة التي ستشعر فيها بالهواء الخارجي
على بشرتك يعرف أفراد عائلتك
هذا أيضًا يمكنني أن أقول من خلال نظرة في
أعيننا حزن عميق لا يوصف
أريد أن أخبرها  لامتصاص كل
لحظة ضحكتما فيها معًا
قل كل كلمة تمنيت لو
قلتها على الإطلاق وافعلها بسرعة الوقت
ينفد من الممرضة التي كتبت
هذا المنشور هي أودري وندت وهي تنضم إلي
الآن أودري شكرًا جزيلاً لانضمامك
نحن هذا الصباح كم من الوقت أتساءل عما
إذا كنت تفكر في نشر هذا
قبل أن تضغط في النهاية على "نشر"
، لقد مرت بضعة أشهر ، لقد كان وقتًا
طويلاً وشعرت أن وقتًا طويلاً
قادم كثيرًا
لقد كانت المشاعر
تتراكم كثيرًا من الحزن ، كنت أرى زملائي
الرائعين في العمل يعملون بجد حقًا ، وكان
بإمكاني رؤيته في جميع أعيننا كنا محترقين
جدًا وأنت نوع من مجموعة من المشاعر
التي تقولها من الوجود  حزين جدًا ولكن أيضًا
غاضبًا نوعًا ما من هذا الموقف ، نعم ،
أعتقد أن هذا شيء
جديد يحدث للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
هو أننا لم نشعر بهذا أبدًا قبل
أن نحب مجتمعنا كثيرًا
ثم نشعر وكأنك تمتلك هذا مثل
الأرض  - السر المثير
وهذا كثير من الناس لا
يستمعون إليه
ومن ثم نراهم في
مستشفياتنا وفي مستشفياتنا
ونشعر بالسوء تجاههم ونشاهدهم
يموتون ونتمنى أن تتمكن من مساعدتهم
فهذا يتطلب خسائر
بالطبع وأنا أعلم أن هذا ليس فقط
عندما تذهب إلى العمل ، فهذا أمر شخصي بالنسبة
لك أيضًا على مستوى آخر لأنك
فقدت شخصًا في حياتك مؤخرًا
شخصان مطمحان لم يتم تطعيمهما
وكان هذا الشخص الذي
ستشجعه للحصول على  لقاح وماذا
يمكنك  أخبرنا حقًا عن هذا ، نعم ،
عمي الحبيب جون ،
نعم ، لقد توفي
بالأمس وكان شخصًا رائعًا حقًا
أم محادثتنا الأخيرة ، كان لدينا واحدة
من آخر ما كنا نلعبه
بالورق وكنت أخبره
أن ما أراه  في حياتي الآن
أمر مروع ومأساوي
وصدقني والحصول على
اللقاح وكان يفكر فيه ولكن
بعد أسبوعين كان على اتصال
بشخص لم يتم
تطعيمه ومرض وتوفي بالأمس
أنت